[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream
108
q and a section
it is still
the eight o'clock class but it's the
nine o'clock hour of the eight o'clock
class and five well yes but uh but the
intention was to start and then we ran
into tech phenomena but
we are here now ready to answer we are
here uh we're gonna do a 45-minute q a
today so let's get to it we've got two
discord questions this week that was a
there were a tie uh they're both
terrific um we need an odd number of
people voting
indeed
um
but i think that we can actually i'd
like to read both of them and maybe
if
let me just read them
because we do actually have a lot of
questions that came in on the on the
other channel as well
first one i am a school board member at
my son's school and i've been trying to
start a discussion about the indoor
requirement of masks on children the
rest of the board would like me to
present information as to why mass
mandates for kids should be dropped
having previously had state and federal
training for hazmat and bioweapons
emergency response i plan on bringing up
improper mass care fit micron sizes
along with the mortality rate for young
children
do you have any additional information
that could help strengthen my position
in my upcoming school board meeting
um i guess
the uh that you know improper mass care
fit micron sizes
mortality rate for young children all
all true and good one obvious thing that
i would add is
um
that we are
absolutely a hundred percent affecting
these children's development and ability
to
um
recognize interpret make sense of and
indeed learn how to
convey meaning with their facial
expressions which is utterly important
to learning how to be a human being that
this is um this is affecting social and
therefore psychological and they're for
mental development uh and at a at a
critical age and especially given um
that many in yeah in a place where
there's mass mandates on school children
presumably other things are also still
curtailed so school is so much of where
kids are getting a lot of their social
interactions and not being able to see
each other is
is
going to have long-term effects down the
road and no it may not be trackable to
this because it's one of these dispersed
long-term effects yeah i would say that
this really
is the answer that all of the we are
in exactly the wrong position trying to
argue that they don't work because then
if they worked a tiny bit which they
probably do
then there's an argument but the point
is actually no it's not worth it this
isn't that kids masked for a month right
to get us through
whatever it was
we're now talking about years of
development in which one of the most
unique features of human beings are
facial expressions and our ability to
convey things
with them are being denied them during a
developmentally critical
period and so at some level the answer
is
even
there is precious little evidence that
kids are a strong contributor
epidemiologically that they are
transmitting lots of disease
but
even if they were transmitting lots of
disease or a certain amount of disease
and even though that does imply that
some old and infirm people are likely to
succumb to a disease that will
ultimately have passed through a child
somewhere children are entitled to that
which they need right we consider it
child abuse to deny a child access to
the world to leave a child locked in a
room this is something like that this is
this is denying them something
fundamentally human and it's not
temporary that's the point when does
this end and
they will not tell us
so this is not based on science
and the harm is quite obvious and
frankly it's time for us to stand up for
children both with respect to vaccines
that do not serve them
medically that the best argument for
them
is
that it protects others but
we don't sacrifice children to protect
others that's not who we are right and
this is that same same theme right they
have they are entitled to a proper
developmental environment and this isn't
a temporary disruption of it so it's
enough already i will just add i i don't
have time to pull it up now but i'm
remembering a graphic
um showing the number and intricacy of
facial muscles in i think maybe a rhesus
macaque some old world monkey to which
we are somewhat distantly related um you
know more closely related than we are of
a cedar tree um less so than to an
orangutan um
and the facial muscles their number and
intricacy in a human and you know when
when you say brett um that that
facial expressions is a big part of how
it is that we communicate this is
actually one of the things that makes us
distinctly human you know there are of
course many many things and there's been
much ink spilled over what it you know
what is the one the thing that makes us
human and you know down that road
nothing really interesting happens
because it's not one thing but the fact
that we can communicate so much more
with our faces
than even our closest relatives can
also tells you something about how much
how much we use that and how much we
need it
okay second discord question for the
week
is given that the supplements companies
are just as susceptible to all the same
perverse market incentives as the big
pharma corporations and with less
stringent fda regulations to begin with
can you talk through how you decide
which supplement company gets your money
and the privilege of getting their
products like vitamin d into the bodies
of your family members no need to give
us your preferred brands if you don't
want to just very curious about your
thought process of who to trust
it's an amazing question and it's we
don't i i don't have a very good answer
except two things
it's not a good answer i have two things
that i can say one is that um
you're absolutely right that there is
actually less accountability um for for
supplements than there is for
things that the fda has has some agency
over um
there are as a result of that i think uh
there are for a number of supplements
there are forms there are molecular
forms they're not actually useful to
humans
are not bioavailable to humans and uh in
a industry in which there is basically
very little accountability you will of
course find you know if if those forms
that are not actually useful or indeed
possibly even toxic to humans are
cheaper to produce
then you will find those in bottles in a
way that are very hard to tell the
difference and in general
they are required
i don't know required in general you
will find
that the actual molecular form of
whatever it is is on the ingredient list
and so
um doing and i i'm not remembering any
of the details right now but doing some
some thinking doing some research into
you know if i'm taking c for instance
vitamin c um what is the form uh which
those researchers slash doctors who have
thought the most about vitamin c and its
effects on the body and how much we need
and how useful it is what is the form
that they say you should be taking it in
and um how do i know that i'm getting
that form one so that's like just a
molecular form and then
imperfect for sure
but to some degree consumer reports
is at least a good first pass like i'll
i'll go to them um
and know that often i won't find
anything and sometimes they'll find
something and you still have to think it
through but they're they're a decent
first pass
yeah i think this is a tremendous
problem yes the room for the room for
people to i mean and the obvious
perverse incentive is it's
harder and more expensive to do stuff
right and if nobody's checking than
creating a substitute for
a nutrient right that superficially the
consumer has no way of knowing
is not functional is a good way to make
a profit or to increase your profit so
it is a problem in addition to that i
would say
i have the added problem of there can't
be any goddamn wheat hiding in it
anywhere right and sometimes there is
and you can't tell because it will say
you know
vegetable gelatin
right
well
vegetable isn't a meaningful term yeah
is the vegetable in question wheat right
um yeah and you know and for me as a
vegetable is a stand-in for plant right
yeah right um
the problem is for me
it's not gluten so even certified gluten
free doesn't nail down whether or not
i'm going to react to it because it's
actually something about wheat i've
figured this out because certain gluten
certifiably
gluten free things that have wheat in
them still trigger me so anyway i'm
constantly scrutinizing labels and
seeing if i can figure it out
which leaves me preferring animal
gelatin which frankly i don't really
want to be eating either but there's not
a good reason not to
and it isn't wheat
um so
yeah that does actually constrain the
choices that we make as a family and you
know maybe figuring out what legitimate
constraints you have and then using that
to help decide between um between
companies but you know we don't
we have not found a brand which makes
supplements that we trust uh would be
very interesting to hear if such such a
thing existed and yet and if so why
why it is that you find them trustworthy
yeah now i also um am
dubious about
uh
standards like organic which have
obviously been gamed to a certain extent
and gmo free but i would say that if
somebody is meeting a standard like this
the chances that they're cheating
elsewhere are probably lower because as
long as they're going to be making a
somewhat more expensive product in order
to meet the standard they're really
appealing to a customer that is actually
looking for something other than just
the label says it's d
um oh i guess one one more thing is
you know we've talked about this before
uh
you know neither of us
ever took supplements at all um the only
time that i ever took supplements before
the pandemic here was when i was doing
long field seasons in madagascar and
eating mostly rice and occasional
reconstituted broth from dried fish
so i felt that there was some chance
that i was going to become deficient in
some stuff and so i took a multivitamin
which i hated doing because
um because you don't know what's in them
and also you know what is limiting for
you is very likely to be different from
what is limiting for someone else so in
general i would say
generic multivitamins even though you
now have shelves and shelves of these
things like this is for women this is
for you know young boy like i don't even
i don't spend any time in these aisles
but i know that they're now
marketing towards different demographics
but no figure out what it is that you
specifically you know as we've talked
about here we are currently we are now
supplementing with d and with c and with
zinc and with quercetin and with
magnesium um as you know and and
and we take all of those as individual
pills which is a pain
um but it means that we take in the
amount that we think we need to take as
opposed to someone else's uh version of
of that
one yeah i had one more thing which is i
do read a lot of reviews
um because sometimes you will find out
on amazon just like that yeah wherever
they happen to be uh you can't always
know if you see a bunch of good reviews
it doesn't necessarily mean anything but
you will often see people flag stuff if
somebody has an allergy and it says
gluten-free but they were triggered
oftentimes you'll see that now of course
there's plenty of room for people to
sabotage each other's reviews and i we
don't know how much of what we see is
that and it's going to be very hard to
get back to you know the reason you're
taking it in the first place is you're
trying to get the product and it's going
to be very hard for individuals
reviewing your product to know you know
did that magnesium pill contain
magnesium in the amount they said it did
was it pure did it have other stuff in
it
very hard to know yeah
you know did it trigger the allergy i
know myself to have that you know that's
a relatively easy so that reviews works
for you know the person like you who is
presumably pretty rare but you know not
as rare as we think who has an acute and
recognizable allergy to a particular
ingredient that shows up in a lot of
places
but it doesn't work i don't think it
will not be very effective to deal with
the question of how do you know you're
getting what you think you're getting
yep
all right first question
from
the
darkhorsesubmissions.com
i remember watching an interview with an
anthropologist some years ago who
referred to cars as an exoskeleton
can we consider our technological
advances as evolutionary trade-offs are
we becoming less human or evolved humans
i feel like that's three
very different questions
you know i think the thing is there's
there's clearly a level at which you're
doing something that is far outside of
the
anticipated
kinds of things that evolution
anticipated you would do
right there's a difference between you
know flying through
you know the air at 500 miles an hour
and a flint knapped uh stone tool for uh
cleaning a hide right
um
but
you know it's a little bit like the
difference between
vocal communication in animals and
language right there are distinctions we
can draw but at some level what you have
is a
variation on a theme in which something
is so extreme that is fundamentally
different
and i don't exactly know where to draw
that line but uh but yeah we are we are
outside of
the anticipated and i think you and i in
our in our book
point to the right thing which is
there is the maximum rate
at which our evolutionary
toolkit for addressing change can keep
pace and anything above that is going to
cause you to be sick and if you're a
little bit above it you'll be a little
bit sick and if you're way above it then
you will constantly have new maladies
and you know people are going to have to
use
wires with tension to move your teeth
around and they're going to have to take
silica and melt it down and shape it
just so and put it in front of both eyes
you can see where you're going and
that's crazy talking
it could happen
so anyway the point is i just can't see
it
no you can't
um
but
pathology after pathology is the result
of the fact that we keep solving
problems and not i mean basically here's
the thing humanity
even you conservatives out there
humanity is liberal and progressive and
it is obsessed with solving problems and
it does not appreciate the full extent
of the unintended consequences of all of
those solutions and we are living
downstream of all of them and it's
messing with every feature of our lives
it's not to say we didn't get a lot out
of it hey we're living longer that's
cool
right we don't die young we don't get
gangrene very frequently but um but the
price has been astronomical and too high
i'm not
you said humanity is liberal and
progressive
but humanity is also traditional and
conservative i would i would say it's
both i i think i know where we're going
with this but obviously i mean part of
part of the point of of our book and of
of how we've lived for decades now
is
you take what has worked in the past and
is still working and you fight hard to
keep it and you also look towards what
has yet to be imagined and you embrace
the new uh
without compromising the old yeah has
been functional and is still working i
i'm not saying that i'm i'm saying
we all maybe the point is we mature
boy the conservatives are going to love
this
we mature into a kind of uh restraint
over problem solving because once you
upend enough [ __ ] by creating a solution
that's worse than the problem yeah right
you begin to learn hey maybe i had to
think carefully about whether or not to
deploy a solution but we all as
individuals
find that
little thing that annoys us and we think
wouldn't it be great to have a yeah fix
that right we just yeah and uh so anyway
for map apps and cars that i've been
talking about for years it's why is it
not out there you know what put it into
the world and let's see if we can get
some of those programmers or the ais
whatever it is that writes programs
these days super simple okay if you live
in a place where you drive from your
home a lot
you and you go and you go places you
live in a city that um has lots of nooks
and crannies and so you tend to put on
the map app when when you go
there if unless there is one well even
if there is one and only one but very
often there will be many ways that you
can get from where you're going to the
sort of the inner circle at which point
you no longer you we will need the map
application after that but you don't
need it for the first
eighth of a mile quarter mile one mile
five miles whatever it is it depends on
the environment you're living in
and yet if you are not to be fiddling
with the application as you're driving
you set it as you go and then i can't
stand the sound so i never have the
sound on but it's also just informing
you of what turns to make even if you
have preferred way to get out of your
immediate neighborhood
there should be a way within the apps to
say okay i'm starting here i'm starting
at a i'm going to b
but don't inform me of how to get to b
until i get to
c which granted that's the wrong order
but i'm going from a to b through c and
thank you very much you don't have to
tell me anything about what to do until
i get to see it which point please kick
in and start informing me yeah or
don't bug me till i say hey siri where
the [ __ ] are we yeah i don't so i don't
have again i don't have the voice
control i can't take the noise from the
thing and i don't want it listening to
me so i don't have right voice
activation on people do use it and they
don't right but for me because this is
my idea i want to be functional for
people also like me who in part don't
want to be bothered with the thing i
don't want it telling me even if it's
just in the visuals wait you took a
wrong turn it didn't take a wrong turn i
live here buddy i know better than you
do what to do here and trust me at the
point that i do get to a place where i'm
not sure what to do i'll be grateful for
your help unless i've thrown you out the
window before then because i'm so
frustrated with you right now i totally
want it to work for you but i also
wanted to work for the kinds of you know
like husbands of people like you it
would be cool if it worked for just like
everybody and you could set it you know
which mode do you want it in
how many husbands of people like me do
you think there are
i'm going to have to sit down and
diagram that sentence and figure out
what the correct answer to that is but
um but i will say one other thing um
getting lost has changed radically in
our lifetime yeah right it used to be
you were a lot more likely to get lost
but when you got lost you weren't that
lost right with these map programs oh
well so i know where you're going but i
will say that i remember um
when would we have even been doing this
i remember driving in new york city
and getting stuck
in new jersey right and
and this is early this is in the 90s or
something like
no idea how to fix this like we were
trying to i think i don't even know
where we're going i know we had started
in manhattan we had not intended to go
to new jersey i remember that and we got
so lost we actually contemplated moving
to new jersey just to solve the problem
right if you if you lived here you'd be
home by now yes yes we're fine deal
done sold
um yeah so i mean that that sort of
thing did happen well no we also got
lost in madagascar once you remember
this
where we lost in madagascar a couple
times we had failed to understand that
in uh most of the southern hemisphere
your northern hemisphere compasses don't
work and so we were trying to navigate
at night with our compass and
we got all tangled yeah
story for another time but anyway the
the thing is though
the the feature that i want on the damn
thing and maybe it exists in there but
it's not obvious where it is is the
ability to check right you plug in
something and then you've clicked away
and it says aha i'll take you there
right
and then you don't know where you're
going you don't know if you've got it
right and it only happens to you
this has never happened to me how could
it not have happened to you
well you've never had your map program
settle on the wrong instance of a
something that there's more than one and
you do check
but how do you check without turning it
off
it doesn't say where it's going well
it's on a map
our our son says i'm right it only
happens well let's let's actually
well okay so from for me
um i because i i actually it's hard like
we all use the app now we all are less
connected to and this this is the point
i think you were ultimately making it's
like getting lost is different now
because
even if we are trying to navigate um by
instinct with our eyes not using the app
okay you know i still try to use paper
maps sometimes although honestly i can't
remember the last time i pulled one out
um we just know our landscapes less well
than we used to um but and you know this
is something i've i've i've told our
boys too
um i don't you know i don't ever get in
the car going someplace i've ever been
until i've looked not in the car and you
know yes it's often on my screen like
okay what part of town is this in you in
the pacific northwest the cities are
broken up into quadrants so all the
addresses tell you is it southwest
southeast northwest northeast that
you're going to or bizarrely portland
has a fifth the north i don't know why
um but
um
so even just that like okay i'm going
okay i'm i'm going to the the southeast
i think i'll probably end up on one of
these two bridges and then i look like
oh wait why is it
that doesn't seem right so like i i do
the little fact check in advance right
you do the fact check in advance and my
point is if you're late to something
you've never been there and you plug in
an address and you
click yes and you can find yourself
across town or all the way across the
continent if you're not paying attention
right i will be curious to know if brett
is in fact the only person this happens
to or if there are a whole lot of other
husbands of people like me to whom it
happens you are going to be frightened
when you find out how many people have
gotten really lost as a result of the
fact that the navigator very effectively
took them someplace that they had no
intention of going and they also live
here now
they live somewhere because it was just
simpler yeah
if they lived there they'd be home by
then
yeah no
um
this is fun
do you have any thoughts around the
benefits of drawbacks of forms of
exercise our ancestors clearly didn't
have weight plates or ellipticals
yeah
oh man we should do a whole episode on
on that
actually
um personally i have almost never been
able to stand being in a gym
and that's partially because of my
strong clear and i've never tried to
hide it biased towards being outside
but also uh because the kinds of things
that you are exposed to outside be it
walking running biking paddle boarding
kayaking
whatever it is
um introduce
uh variation into what you're doing that
actually yes keeps you more interested
um but you know so you're more likely to
keep doing it i at least at least people
like me are um
but also it's more likely to actually
train your body for the kinds of things
that you will run into so you know if if
you're if you're just
exercising in order to for your body not
to fall apart and um you don't imagine
ever needing to use it for anything
outside of basically getting between
home and gym then whatever you're doing
at the gym might be sufficient um but
even just the experience of i'm fit you
know i'm okay i'm i'm working out i'm
doing this you know ellipticals weight
plates whatever it is um reliably and oh
i have to you know reach the thing on
the top shelf i'm just going to stand on
my tippy-toes and reach for like oh god
that wasn't a way that i was supposed to
be moving right like that sort of thing
which we've all heard stories like that
whether or not you've experienced or not
you you know the kind of thing i'm
talking about is going to be less likely
to happen if you if you're using your
body regularly in all sorts of in all
sorts of ways on every plaintiff
movement with burst speed with
low and slow you know with all of the
possible things that you might
experience such that um
oh the
street sign changed since you were
halfway across a long intersection can
you run to make it you should be able to
at you know at almost every age this
happened to me yesterday um and you know
i actually i remember
a couple years before the boat accident
just knocked me off
um i was not in great shape for maybe
the first time in my life and this
happened to me and i just ran to across
the street i was you know mid-40s or
something at that point it's like
huh that didn't feel good why am i stiff
and weird all over like gotta fix that
you gotta be able to run half a block
gotta i'd rather be able to run a lot
more than that but um so you know to the
degree that you're you know the narrowly
constrained types of exercises
will provide a narrowly constrained type
of fitness but i think i think you're
drawing it too uh
too sharply
um i even think
the difference between
running in the city
and trail running for example is a huge
difference right sure
and there's something about the
regularity the more regularity in some
sense the worse it is and also the more
you know i'm uh
very much a
fan of bicycling and i do a lot of it
even in the winter but the point is it's
very good lower body exercise it's not
such great upper body exercise now
mountain biking especially single speed
mountain biking which i used to do was
actually pretty good upper body but
regular road biking is not
and um yeah you actually have to
of
muscle
yeah
you're
pulling the the front of the bike and it
works better but anyway so you know
having a kind of exercise it's good for
cardio it's you know good for your lower
body not so great for your upper body so
it'd be great to match it with something
like kayaking that's more upper body or
whatever but
um but anyway the
lack of regularity is your friend in
more ways than one one
you build a model of something rather
than you know you're running on a
perfectly flat concrete surface um two
it forces you
it to exceed limits right
and so the point is
if you think about you know the old
version of uh you know muscle building
involved a lot of repetition but the
point is the repetition would work if
you were a simple physical system it
does not work if you're an informational
system trying to figure out how strong
to be an engineer's approach yeah you
keep lifting the same weight and the
point is you're not telling the body
actually you need to be stronger than
this the way to do that is actually to
just barely not be able to lift
something right
yeah test
find your limit and then try to go
beyond it on the regular yeah you know
and also um you know not be at that
limit all the time
but but change it up yeah i will also
say
the
fact of
anything that you do that forces you to
confront the variation in
weather including temperature but
rainfall and all of that
has a psychological benefit that nothing
else matches and i must say any day that
i don't spend significant time
forced to confront the weather and i
don't always want to do it but um but
just the simple fact of this was one of
those days and then oh it's much better
today has a you know time doesn't
all blend together anymore no no it's
it's amazing and you've been um so
you've been biking to school with toby
uh most mornings and you know it's very
december out there at this point uh but
you know boy
you guys do it and it's amazing well
actually this is something to return to
another day but i've been thinking about
you know it's
dressing
for
biking in the pacific northwest in the
winter and this is true in michigan also
is very very difficult
because
basically you're not built for this
you are built to regulate your
temperature with your skin and your
capillaries and if you put something
over that either you're shedding heat
into your jacket and then the point is
you get really hot and then you get
really clammy right or you aren't
capturing enough heat and so you get
really cold and so you're shooting for
this very narrow range and it requires
and you're going at speed so you're
right you're adapted to regulate your
heat with your skin
at human speeds not at you know bicycle
speeds where the boundary layers are
blowing away your your either your
insulative level layer
um if you're if you've got the stuff on
or you're even colder than you are if
you don't if you're exposing your skin
to them right so there are a bunch of
things like
in december
if you feel comfortable when you've left
the house you're going to be hot right
away right you need to be uncomfortable
for a while in order to reach
comfortable but the trick is how do you
build up the right level of boundary
layer which varies with the temperature
of the day and the nature of the
precipitation
right exactly right because you're
dealing with two different substances
that have two different specific heats
you're dealing with air rushing over you
versus water falling on you and then
uh dripping away yeah i think the one
thing we can agree on is that cotton is
your enemy in this situation yeah cotton
cotton sucks yeah i mean i love it
normally
i'm wearing any at the moment um but
yeah for exercise it just you know it
gets wet and stays wet yep okay um yeah
we could go on and on about that one
we are
we only have 15 15 more minutes okay
um
can you explain your thoughts on flu
vaccines specifically the theory that
repeated vaccination in young children
may lead to less protection when they
are older
you know i have not heard that actually
um i've not heard that
i am
ever more convinced that we are taking
this most precious of resources which is
the ability to vaccinate against
pathogens and we are
treating it frivolously and wasting it
and
i am suspicious of the flu vaccine now i
am also
concerned that we are going to hit a
very serious
flu epidemic and i'm also i the last flu
i had which was
i don't know five or six years ago was
terrible i just it was it really
knocked me on my ass but
um so it's not that i take flu lightly
but the question is
what's the net impact right and i'm not
compelled that you know
vaccine because vaccine has a positive
connotation with respect to health that
more is better that the vaccines are
formulated in the correct way
and i mean and we know with right of the
flu vaccine that it's a probabilistic
estimate of you know which which of the
ones that were circulating
like half a year ago in the southern
hemisphere are likely to be the ones
that are dominant now here and you know
did we guess right is this is this in
fact the right vaccine for the moment
like even you know aside from all of
that like it's the efficacy varies by
year precisely because which versions of
which viruses are circulating varies
well i also
you know now that i've watched the
manufacturers
treat covert the way they have and lie
to us about what they know
i i now don't know what to think about
the fact that you know
there's a whole lot of variation
every year are there ever years in which
they make things worse
right right is there ade with respect to
flu i don't know but
um
yeah i certainly i mean you know we
can't do this at the anecdotal level but
i certainly wondered this anecdotally
when i had a flu vaccine in late 2019
and in february 2020 had and gave to
zack and you and toby seem to have not
gotten it or maybe you did and didn't
show it either cobin
or
the most unusual really heinous flu that
i've i've had yeah um and
um and it was the first time i'd had a
flu vaccine in a few years and
um
yeah i don't know i also i also am now
pretty sure
they have not given us and this is true
for so many consumer items but in this
case this is your health we're talking
about they don't give us enough
information to behave rationally right
right okay you've got an adjuvant in
this vaccine should you be
really careful what you eat and for how
long right should you be extra careful
are you
say another two words about that because
that that's that's important the idea
that for instance
um
your
wheat sensitivity may all you may also
have some other sensitivities because
whatever it is that prompted whatever it
is in the wheat or in you that prompted
an allergy to happen may have basically
taken out created sensitivities to
whatever was else was in your gut at the
same time right exactly and so an
adjuvant may create sensitivity that
then may co-create sensitivity for
anything else that is in your system at
the same time right so basically it's an
irritant that awakens the immune system
to get a stronger response and there are
reasons to do that because there are
tradeoffs in these things
a live
virus an attenuated virus vaccine tends
to produce a very good
immunological response but because it's
a live virus it runs the risk of
of mutating and
becoming pathogenic
but
if you take uh a killed virus for
example it doesn't produce a very strong
response because the body doesn't really
understand itself to be infected because
it isn't right and so they add these
adjuvants to awaken the immune system
but they don't say hey by the way
you know for the next two weeks you
might want to avoid these things which
are very likely to get picked up by the
immune system and it could cause you to
have a lifelong sensitivity to peanuts
now i don't know that peanuts is or
isn't but i do know that that's a story
i want to know more about what they know
about what the adjuvants can do rather
than just have the pretense that you
know hey because it comes in a syringe
it's good for you yeah no exactly and
you know specifically the idea that
actually for the whatever it is one week
two weeks whatever it is post
uh injection
uh you are potentially more at risk
um not just maybe from the disease in
the case of the covered vaccines at
least
but more at risk of creating for
yourself a lifelong immune problem
unless you take great care is something
i've never heard from any health
professional right right and and the
thing is you know you don't need to know
very much about things like antibodies
to see that there would there is a
question that has to be answered right
because
um if you are so
you've got flu viruses that are closely
related to each other and if you've had
the flu before that means you've got
antibodies to things in that
neighborhood right
at the point that you've been injected
with something an antigen that is going
to trigger it is going to occupy a
certain amount of the antibodies that
you have to things in the neighborhood
right now
that could leave them detained while you
encounter actual flu so it might be that
the answer is hey
don't wait until
flu is here
right
get it before flu is here and
be careful of these influences for
whatever the period is maybe it's a day
maybe it's a week but
somebody should tell us right and
there's just not enough info
they treat us like children and
pretend it's just simply an unallowed
good yeah no that's right
okay we're gonna not get to a lot of
questions today let's try to run through
it quickly okay um
hello i don't want to rush through this
one but hello i'm a canadian afghan war
vet i was just wondering if you would
expand on ptsd from the evolutionary
lens
what might modern humans do to help
prevent or facilitate
it
facilitate presumably meaning like treat
get through it
um i gotta go for it quick riff
thing is you're a human being and just
like a human population you are built to
be able to deal with radical change
right what we do not seem to be well
equipped to do is do radical change
twice right in other words imagine that
you had a radical change in your life
where you went from being a something to
a something else you know you changed
careers or something like this or
you were a
you know a carpenter and suddenly you're
a soldier right you're a soldier there
are people dying around you you can
adapt to that right what you have a hard
time adapting to is going back to a life
where you don't have to worry that
there's a sniper in the supermarket
right and so the point is that second
this is why it's post-traumatic stress
right it's not something you are built
to unlearn right you matured into
soldier and you can't successful
soldiers get through the actual trauma
intact
usually yeah i mean
or they don't or they don't but but the
point is you're not built to be able to
forget what you learned about
death at war for example
um and so
i there is a lot you probably want to
avail yourself of some kind of um
a
hack that will allow you to revise this
so things you know
probably supervision is highly
recommended but people do find that
enthusiasm are good at reprogramming the
mind in part because they can create
very intense like psilocybe mushrooms or
ayahuasca right for instance so um very
intense
um
open-minded experiences that if you
guide yourself into confronting
the issues that you're having trouble
getting past will allow you to write
some new code yeah no i think that's
that's great like you know this too i
think we could do a whole lot on i would
also recommend just again
this tribe by sebastian younger on
homecoming and belonging and also his
book war which i mean i think i've read
everything he's written all of the books
he's written at this point and they're
all great but tribe and war
will will speak to you i think
specifically
as well
do you think it is likely that
electromagnetic radiation of wireless
tech has a negative impact on organisms
would this be hard to detect
it's
tough
non-ionizing radiation
is
sure to be
much safer
it's possible that up to some threshold
of energy it's safe
in fact it's likely that there's a
threshold but where that threshold goes
is a little tough there have been a lot
of people who've looked into it
and i would say i do think we need to be
aware that the higher the energy
and the closer our
proximity to the sources the greater the
danger
and it is quite possible that the
perverse incentives in our system
will prevent people from alerting us at
the point
that we have created hazards for
ourselves
yes um
oh we just did that one
uh let's see
have you read the real dr fauci by
robert kennedy jr
shocking what he lays out
we've both uh begun to read it yeah we
have it's it's it's long and really
important and um
we recommend it yes
yes
um
what the [ __ ] is up with the 55-year lag
the fda claims it needs to process the
foia request on the pfizer vaccine
licensing data
that is there
because it is important that the people
committing these crimes either have died
or become so powerful that they are
beyond prosecution by the time we know
what has happened
so that sounds about right yeah yeah
might you have bob tribbers on at some
point i bet we'd all enjoy hearing a
conversation with someone who helped you
build your evolutionary toolkit yeah i
would love to have bob on there's lots
of stuff uh
i would love to run by him actually yeah
he actually we've just been in touch
with him again he's
he's reading our book and um and
he's
he sent us kudos which felt really
really great yeah sure did yeah
um i do not know the answer to this
question but um you might
hi i finally found a doctor that would
order a nucleocapsid antibodies test i
had covered seven months ago the
antibody level has to be at least
17.8 igg and i have 91.3
however i was told not to read too much
into that number from my immunity status
any idea what levels of antibodies are a
risk for infection
wait wait wait wait wait this person had
coveted yeah they recovered they've had
an antibody test
and they are at um five times the level
that is considered um yeah
this is so frustrating first of all
antibodies are not where the primary
immunity to this virus is coming from
it's a proxy right what it's telling you
is how well your immune system reacted
to this thing but you actually expect
the antibody level to drop precipitously
afterwards right
it goes into a memory cell phase
and
the fact is we have excellent evidence
that natural immunity is extremely
durable now you could get enough
evolution that you would face some new
variant that would have less protection
but so far as we know the protection you
get
seems to be
lifelong
now obviously nobody's had it for very
long but the point is
immunities are often lifelong unless
there's something about the pathogen
that makes that impossible where the
pathogen is so rapidly evolving that
that can't be the case but that does not
appear to be the case here so
what i would say is yeah don't read too
much into that test what you should read
something into is the spectacular level
of immunity that people who've actually
had covet appear to walk away with right
that's the key thing and
you know there there's debate about how
many breakthrough cases there are for
people's natural immunity but in fact i
learned from dr mccullough and you
should
uh check out my podcast with dr
mccullough yeah that in fact it may be
that there are vanishingly few
breakthrough cases
well he claims zero my question is is a
supply to immunocompromise people i
don't know but for people who have
helped the immune system the number may
actually be zero because of course there
are false positives to the test so what
you want to establish is that what
you've got is something above the
baseline of false positives yes and we
do not have that evidence so i would say
you know you you would be safe to assume
you have natural immunity which doesn't
mean be reckless but it does mean
you don't need to go face some
substantial risk in order to gain more
immunity which wouldn't work anyway okay
i wanted to get through four more
questions three minutes but now we have
30 seconds so can we do it yes okay does
your culture versus consciousness
hypothesis make any testable predictions
thanks for your work lots of love yeah
it makes lots of testable predictions
including you know you could get right
down to
the uh
the mechanistic level of makes
predictions about what parts of the
brain will
light up under different kinds of
circumstances on an fmri machine
you could try to beat the um
the
limit of only being able to put a person
in an fri machine by you know pooling
people and having them scanned in
at the same moment for example so yes it
makes lots and lots of predictions some
of them uh only
technically testable many of them quite
practical
remember when we were told the vaccines
were 98 effective was that a flat out
lie or were the trials designed to
affect no other outcome
i don't know
um
there's so much
in the trials that appears to you know i
think i think the point is it doesn't
it's not even clear what the number
itself means if it is a hundred percent
true right
that's what the meaning of effectiveness
right so anyway there's lots of
shenanigans including surrounding that
number um yeah
and frankly i think the the thing people
nee really need to think about is that
this is actually standard operating
procedure for pharma yeah right that's
not that's not unique to covet at all
yeah it's a
standard
operating
procedure for pharma as per as laid out
in bad pharma how drug companies must
see doctors and harm patients and ben
gold acres book
um
second to last question i can't work or
travel without a vaccine now in canada
when i provide sources for my arguments
they dismiss it how do i get this
information past the social wall that
people have put up they all seem
brainwashed
this is a big question obviously yeah
and it's not just canada right
but i mean canada is um
ahead of the us in terms of um
restrictions
behind australia and new zealand it
seems at least parts of australia and
germany i think
yeah um
so i don't know i mean this is uh in
part i think it's not down to you right
i think we all vaccinated and not need
to stand up against an absolutely absurd
set of mandates that are not science
based and
um
i don't think there's any advice you can
give an individual you obviously know
what they're threatening you with and
their threat is obviously credible
um
you know and yeah so
well good luck to you i
i wish that this is the problem because
you don't have any protection as an
individual from this the the tyranny is
quite powerful
final question
why are human beings attracted to shiny
objects such as gold or jewels um
well
it's an interesting quote so first of
all it'd be interesting to know whether
or not we are attracted to shininess
which i think there's an argument that
we are right we also like uh the way
light shines off the water that's
exactly the example i was going to give
and um sunrise and sunset is a shiny
moment yep and uh we are captivated by
the glistening of snow
and the the shininess on on organisms
you know on on the iridescence
iridescence on beetles on butterfly
wings on some feathers on yeah
hummingbirds they're okay
um
so i think there are a couple answers to
your question one
what shininess is
is
often a hint to something special right
it is a molecular specialness
the the iridescence on bird feathers and
butterfly wings is a very precise
shelf-like structure there's no pigment
there it's actually the two examples you
get uh butterfly wings and uh and bird
feathers
the iridescence
i think bird fight it it happens both
ways on bird feathers oh they're
structural it's sometimes structural no
no the iridescence is always structural
there is of course iridescence is always
structural yeah that's why it's
iridescent looking even not in either of
those two examples but unlike a beetle
carapace
um
i don't know but i would guess so
because i think the point is the
iridescence is the result of the fact
that as you move you're changing what
interference pattern yeah it's an
interference pattern
um but in any case the point is it is an
indicator of something special this is
why the birds are displaying this
basically male birds are telling female
birds you know uh i have just that
precise yeah or i'm just that clean or
i'm just that well fed that i can make
this molecularly precise little shelf
all over my feathers or whatever
um
but the point is okay for some reason
doesn't work as a pickup line
it's just too technical how do you know
i can imagine oh
um i can i can put myself in the brain
of a female bird i see i see all right
i guess i also just said it and you must
not have felt anything so really didn't
yeah all right but then you're also not
iridescent so you appear to be lying
all right yeah i think you won that
round um
but okay so the point is all of the
things that you know
a a gem that has sheared and has left a
face smooth enough for it to to cause
that shininess is worth investigating it
might be a rare gem or it might just
indicate a deposit in the rocks or
something but it's a piece of
information and so anyway i would just
argue that shininess is a hallmark of
something
we of course have extra
because we've learned to polish things
uh because we've learned to make glass
very smooth and then put silver there's
sort of an added
we we can get utility out of these
things but but it also i mean
one of the simplest answers here also is
that um we've made shininess ubiquitous
and cheap in the marketplace
excuse me but china used to be an
indicator of uh value and also fairly
rare right so a gift of shiny uh was an
indicator of i care enough because um
this shiny thing isn't something that i
just picked up on my way to you i
couldn't have it's fairly rare
here i
this this is the evidence that i was
thinking of yes i must love you because
i'm giving you this shiny thing which
you know that i want because i'm a human
and therefore i like shiny things it's
shiny i'm giving it to you right love me
exactly
and there you have it there it is yep
yep all right um
i think we've arrived this has been a
little
fast-paced and scattered today guys but
we'll be back next week at the normal
time i believe at 12 30.
and um
go to darval's to pick up a darval's
bookstore online to pick up to order a
signed copy of our book uh go on to our
patreons right now the question asking
period is open at mine
lots of other things to talk about oh
gift giving on my sub stack this week on
natural selections
and
until we see you next be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
you